[Music]
are you ready yes
you got the goods jackson high five
admire the wrapping who wrapped this
this was pretty rad
this one's cool
happy holidays hi i'm hannah i'm the
world's okay mom and if you're anything
like me the holidays can stress you out
a little bit so i've decided to go easy
on myself and let my kids do all of my
holiday shopping for our entire family
hopefully they don't get anything too
weird but we all know it's gonna be
interesting for sure so wish me luck so
the plan is i'm going to give the boys
50 per person i feel like it's enough
money to get something meaningful
without going overboard and whatever the
boys choose
that's going to be that person's gift
for the holidays for real and i wanted
this to be as much of a surprise as
possible so especially for the gifts for
me matt the kids i let them
just do the online shopping and i
completed the checkout without looking
at what the gift was what are you guys
doing
just searching her your present
the only thing i'm nervous about is more
poop memorabilia in my house because we
all know how my kids love to troll so
first up we needed to get gifts from my
sisters now i have four younger sisters
they range in age from 15 to 23. i feel
like that's a tall order to shop for
you know a 20 year old girl especially
if you're a little boy okay guys
who is this gift for
do you know what you want to get her
yeah
well okay there's only one place for us
to go for this
and we better hurry before it closes so
let me take my
all right let's go
i'm really close with my sisters we see
them all the time my boys are really
close with my sisters so i think this
just shows how well they know them
because when we started shopping for
them i was thinking oh my gosh this is
spot-on
now the department in which they needed
a lot of help was wrapping which
i think is super funny i personally
don't really care about gift wrapping at
all i think it's a waste of paper and a
waste of time so i tend to wrap as
little as possible but honestly it makes
it way more fun letting the kids just go
crazy with the wrapping paper and come
up with whatever they want because it
makes for some really funny packages
that's it let's give it to her i'm so
great
it's a makeup advent calendar it's the
makeup advent calendar
this is on my christmas list
what yeah
thank you did they do a good job silly
yeah they did a great job thank you high
five
jackson high five forgive me
then for gabby they made a couple stops
into different stores because she has a
little more of a broad taste and so they
wanted to get a little bit of everything
for her and
again something that just screamed gabby
which is so cool to me
wow look at that wrapping what's this is
this wrapping paper
i didn't want anyone to see
this one's
very efficient i like the type of choice
wait this is so cute
oh my god is it
it's a dream decoder dream decoder jack
oh my god this is so
a cool of wrapping paper
apples with skincare that's so nice
did they do okay they did great
did alfalfa do okay
alfalfa
the girls were very touched they were
very grateful very touched they loved
their gifts so after i saw what they got
the girls i really trusted them a lot
more for the rest of the gifts
next up is the most difficult person in
our entire family to shop for
take a wild guess that's amazing yeah
it's matt
matt is particular he is particular
about his likes dislikes he has
kind of bougie tastes so if it's
difficult for me to find something for
him i can't imagine how tough it must be
for the boys to try to find something
for him
or it could go the totally opposite
direction where i am overthinking his
gifts and maybe the boys have an easier
time because they're just buying from
the heart
two items number one dad
and
a mug
but you need to see what the mug is
is it a cactus
no mug it is a cactus mug there's a
really lengthy to explain inside joke in
our family where we call him cactus
not because he's a prick
maybe no
this is cool thank you guys
i'm the number one dad will you actually
use that mug yeah sure
if it's a mug and it's clean i will use
it he's always drinking coffee he loves
his coffee he loves coffee mugs so it
was a really great gift
oh that's cute
cute guys
so maybe i am overthinking it and i
should just ask the boys what to get him
from now on because he really enjoyed
the gift and
it went really well
now next is me and i really am not a
huge gift person i don't like receiving
gifts
i love to give gifts so i was curious to
see what the boys were gonna get because
i maybe i'm difficult to shop for too
because i just don't really need
anything first let's
admire the wrapping who wrapped this me
and wyatt
jackson was the one who happened there
are some spoilers in this wrapping
actually
it's a crystal clean
it looked way bigger oh this is just so
pretty
it's got like a titanium
crystal on the bottom and are these
amethysts on the top hey good thank you
so much you guys know how much
[Music]
i love crystals so
it was so me it's the one thing that i
will never have enough of i think i've
made it really clear that i'm obsessed
with crystals i mean my whole house is
covered in them
i love to forage for them we go hunting
for crystals together as a family we
went to quartzite to the crystal shop on
our trip to the grand canyon
and the boys have definitely picked up
on it that i'll never say no to a
crystal no matter how many i have i
didn't know i got a second part to my
gift
yep
oh it's so cute
thank you that's my book no this is mine
i'm no longer the world's okaiest mom
i'm the number one mom
oh i love this mug thank you boys so
much
so cute that it said number one mom
because they tell me all the time
they're like you're not the okay mom
you're the best mom so that means a lot
to me so up next was henry
henry that's not the present what's in
there
oh is that a moon
henry
so they got him a moon lamp like a
personal
rubber lamp shaped like a moon which is
so thoughtful and there's a deeper
meaning to this too because the moon
obsession runs deep to the point that if
it's a new moon and we can't go outside
to say goodnight to it he has a
full-blown like smackdown tantrum and so
for those nights when the moon isn't out
we can have his little moon lamp and he
can hold it and say goodnight to it and
it's actually super helpful for everyone
is that
moonlight
yellow all right it's the moment you've
been waiting for
what did the boys get for each other
they had this 50 budget so they were
able to get each other two things okay
let's open it okay you want to help him
oh
it looks pink
oh my gosh yeah i wanted
a lego set so bad
this one's cool
so jackson got a spaceship little toy
brick set which i guess he had told
wyatt he wanted and marked it in a
little catalog so that was really cute
that wyatt remembered that and
got it for him because he was super
excited to build it right away
hmm
it's our kids watch
yes
and then jackson got wyatt a watch which
if you know wyatt you know he is very
into style
he's a style icon and so
he has been coveting a watch for a very
long time but he wants a really good
looking watch and wyatt was thrilled it
was the cutest thing to see because he
was so in awe of this watch he wears it
every day he sleeps in it he uses it all
the time it lights up he can set timers
it's a little stopwatch too he's
obsessed
jackson even made a card for wyatt on
the wrapping that was so sweet and
thoughtful he folded it up all cute and
it was just a really sweet touch to add
to the gift
happy holidays
because i ended up having to help them
through a little bit of this purchasing
process i knew what they were giving
each other and they were giving each
other the exact same thing okay one two
three
yeah it's a no shockwave
because the boys are homeschooled right
now they're together 24 7. they're
together all the time
and it has been
really awful in some ways where they're
really sick of each other and they get
on each other's nerves but it's also
been really special in some ways where
they really confide in each other and
they talk about their interests and they
talk about shared interests and their
hopes and dreams and all of that so this
was a reflection to me of all the time
they've spent together how well they
know each other now and how close they
are so that was it for the family but we
weren't done giving just yet we have one
other holiday tradition we do it every
year this is the third year in a row
and it is so meaningful to us so we had
to include it so for the past three
years during the holiday season i ask my
instagram followers to send me their
holiday wish list and so i set aside
money through the year
to
my little wish list fund and then i get
to as many wish lists as i possibly can
until the money runs out
so you know how every year i do the
amazon wish list and i let people submit
their wishlist
for gifts and i usually just
do a lot of them myself
well today for this holiday gift you get
to go through someone's wish list and
choose the gifts
for another kid
or kids
are you ready yes okay so let's scroll
through
so usually this is a whole family thing
that we do together but because i'm
letting the boys do the holiday shopping
i let them go through a bunch of the
wish lists and hand-pick items that they
thought other kids would enjoy
which was so fun for them they honestly
had more fun shopping on the wish list
than shopping for everyone's gifts
i think the significance of letting the
boys do the holiday shopping is first of
all understanding the value of a dollar
but most importantly it's about putting
other people first how did you feel
about this week
it was really fun
what'd you think about giving the gifts
[Music]
do you think everybody liked them yeah
and you know what's more important than
gifts
but
giving
spending time with family family
drinking hot chocolate thank you for the
gifts guys
thank you so much
i loved it whoa
so that's all for now i'm wishing you
and your loved ones an amazing and happy
holiday season and tune in for some
really exciting news coming next year
hint you've been asking for this for a
very long time now if you'll please
excuse me the number one mom has some
coffee to drink until next time cheers
[Music]
you